give it a habit how's it going bros my
property back today we're gonna play
geometry dash i don't know why but it's
the highest rated game on the iPhone
store it looks pretty oh it cuz like
characters this is me his name is solid
this game is supposed to be really hard
I don't know if this one is but you know
what there's only one way to find out so
let's play yeah oh my god I'm so good at
this
Jesus I'm the best player in the world
bring it oh damn what I'm so cute he's
so happy this is his dream he always
wanted to be a submarine going through
space and [ __ ] mainly [ __ ] actually I
don't know I said space what is
happening I mean no don't you die now no
all of it oh my god it's gonna be so
annoying
sorry what if he slide so hard he must
have been rubbing his entire body filled
with oil before he did this I do that
too before everyone in my videos it's a
secret how do you think I get so many
subscribers yes no I got 3% out of that
shut up oh my god how long is this gonna
go I can't handle this I'm not good with
stress okay okay don't you die now you
little [ __ ] come on go inside that hole
yes achievement high final that's how
you high-five in Sweden trust me I know
because I'm Swedish no per hour you can
do practice practices with nailed it
like yo ma ma no got it no I don't got
it it's like flappy bird except there's
no flapping genius
Nadine Jeff lafon QB Oh No 1% I'm like a
rhythm aunty person whatever it's called
great now you distract it thanks it's
all your fault don't worry I fell on you
really I was talking to Edgar don't
worry look at that [ __ ]
and mm why am i wearing headphones
there's no [ __ ] audio yeah that's
funny
you're [ __ ] funny you little [ __ ]
yeah 29 I'm so happy now now yeah it's a
video honk honk out of it yes every
goddamn time you little wagon right
don't take all right we're on the road
baby yes Oh Victor beat I said Victor
why did I die
seriously Germans what why bye
I unlocked a new color [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna change color I can see my [ __ ]
news oh I locked in you call it you're
just teasing me at this point you [ __ ]
oh I don't understand why I'm so bad at
this
I was born to play games do you even
know what my KD is it's like 0.5 yeah oh
my god dad [ __ ] won every [ __ ]
time man I don't want to read a magazine
do I look like how I not even magazine
it's just a face to make what do you
want to buy magazine oh well I better
read a magazine men I think they broke
the game because he kept me he keeps
jumping
good job hits okay there I remember you
you little [ __ ] that's right
oh I'm so bad I'm so [ __ ] bad man I'm
not bad man I wish I was
yeah it's [ __ ] head so it's tough to
like bad I said whatever I was doing
good
yeah
okay 100% focus now I'm not gonna talk
I'm not gonna I'm just gonna focus oh
[ __ ] you know what I have to practice
right I have to do a practice mode okay
Wow
I completed the practice time for the
real thing I guess many Jabba Fichte
don't bother I share the pressure we are
live in a blue [ __ ] submarine
missiles OH
don't [ __ ] that don't do day alright
this part is really hard
hmm [ __ ] you come on come on clap or
some [ __ ] I don't know it should go
shake your titties shaking thing next
time you shaved your [ __ ] titties are
we clear this face doesn't care but the
feelings does really care
oh how did you did time to shake those
[ __ ] nice titties you have did I tell
you to stop
yes oh my god
I was so easy oh my god I don't know if
I can do another one okay cool I can
double jumping [ __ ] my god I'm the best
player in the world
Oh
stressing me okay I'm gonna get a heart
attack
no no oh my god I was so close
come on I don't think I got in this far
ah what when is this map ever gonna end
okay we're doing it I'm gonna [ __ ] do
it I've made up my mind
nice okay we can do this Bros hold my
titties why don't you have her hold them
oh come on come on come on come on come
on come on come on Catman can my own
come on come on I wanna
you like my hair is that it you like it
you like it I love all away for hours to
be God dad this game is so annoying
it actually it's actually pretty funny
but it's [ __ ] hard man
anyway I hope you enjoyed watching go
ahead and leave a like if you liked it
and see me suffer I guess this guy's
gonna read today I see you bros say
awesome love you